people who don't have money are being
encouraged to kill themselves in Canada
what new poll out shows that 28 percent
of Canadians approve of assisted suicide
for homeless people I'm Don goodbye a
fifth of respondents said that medical
assistance in dying which is the real
clinical jargony way of saying assisted
suicide should be offered as an option
to anyone regardless of medical or
psychological condition but then a
greater number than that not quite a
third but getting pretty close said that
homeless people should be permitted to
kill themselves this always happens I
guess the theme of the show today is the
slippery slope and you will hear
philosophers and you will hear social
scientists and you'll hear politicians
say oh please don't please stop making
those silly slippery slope arguments why
I can I can barely make a slippery slope
argument right now because the wind is
going so fast in my face winds going
through my hair I'm going down that
slide so fast